AGWHAT CSHING ACCINE
THAT"REL>>
BIGGEST STY
THAT YOUWHAT HAPCNN ESHESOE TORO
CUOMO'S FIRINGH A
WHY WAS CHRID NOW
NAPORTED
HIM ALL YEAR LONG?
QUESTION I HAVE  PURIN MEDIA P
SOERSWERS I VEAR.K K TO
E  CUMENT DUMP.WITH A THUD.S LO.
BOUT CIS
AHIM OF THAT. HE PP HIS BROTHEU
BETWEEN CUE 'S
HA TNY
T RUNITS TIME TO
W.S PRODUCERS
REK TO PROANOTISPRIMETIME"HE GR
NGEMEN
EO WAINITELY," PEFU
MNOT UNTIL JUST
EE FOR
NI
MAD.LSFTN
" FROM THAT. TT WAS BAINHANDS OF
FEELTHPORTERS
OUNES AND DAMAGINGNDS ANSIDE, C
CUOMPERSON FS LY.YOU LTNE WAS W
CA
YI SHOULD HAVEN
FROMWES GHAYCALL
ANSTS,KING TO.GSIS CNN HAD AN TP
TOEE
NNS JE
TAFF'S SHOW AND TH
AUT THE PRIDE THE SHOW.RERTLYFH
SO THERE WAS AL WIDE ARRAYLINGSG
GET RID OFDN'T  HERE, HOU HAV O
L
.UL
THER THINGT S
ITH 245  O THE STAFF AHE PUBLIC.
AN ANOUSRKED WITH CUO "THE NEW R
OF THE SAME ALLEGATIONS THATCAEE
INFORMATION
O LIGH IT WA
NOTHING ABOULLEGATION.EGATION.GS
NOG HAS BEEN REPD ABOU
IT PUBLICLY OTHER THANOR
A'L.
IN FRIDAY.
THE LAFI ITS RIED D CNN
DECISIAROF COMEX .F THTURDAY.
CHRIA STATEMENT, HE
DIDN WIS WAY THEY'VE
UCT CLAI, E TH NEWS LATE  SG SHI
CASS HASED FSE APPARENPONTOTRS ?
ENDT  OF HE
THOUSANGHT WH
CUTS.
BYAGING SENSE BACKED TT
UP.
THIS IS NOT  A SINGLE HEADACUTAT
IT SEEMS CNND TO TERMINATE
VIEWFACEOCT DUMPONOTHER D ENSC
A CNN SPOKESPERSG ERNIGHT EN
ALLEGATION CAMS THISOTM SLY SANN
DEE,ER ESNTOWNS   ONREREVEAL MO
ANS ALGAS AR
HERE'SOTTO UNPACK
BEEN A BRUISINGR N, ANDIFAND T
TRANSPARENT AS WCAWIWITH ME NOA.
PROFESSOR
MEDIA STUDIES ATOLLEGE
T OF
NBC.
AN ASSEM
SARA, YOU HAVE BRE
THISAS IAVE.AT ARE THEIGWNESTIO?
>> B YOU
ONCE THE ALLEGNSAD CAU Y.AN CTI
DIATELY FIREIMI ALSO WAN KNOABT
INVEST SAY THEREO
MATTERURATE
E O COMMIT
MAKING T FT
STEN?
CNN, ABOUT TUL, ABOUT
SO MAN IN NEWS HALR
.
DOES THIS CHANGE THE W
K ABOUT HOW RTD TS ANDEA
WIIONS?
I ASSUMEE WILL T AS TIM ON.
>> GAT.ED CASE
E THIS LY
WITH CUOMOG THIS
OFHE PDU CURRENTLY
PRAISES, AND THEY --T
THE PEOPLE I TALKE -- EDS
TMA MEDRR
RESULT O
RIGHT.TH SAYF CN TRUST.K IS REA
THLATIONTHERW ABOU.
ITNGS THAT
MA NOTY,Y
DOT TRT T'S LEET
WITH ELITEKING CAROF .
RE WE
WATCH SOME PEOPLE HARDER THAN
RELATIONSHIPS, PEOPLE TRYING TOM
WELOST SENSEF MEETHICS.
OUR PRO ESPECIALLY INEWU HAK YA
IN SOMK CNN MADE
TH
TO ASK IT, FOR?
E ANYOURLOT CHECK.BUT BEYOND TLN
YOU SHOULD BE SERVINE
ICS PUTS YOU AWITH PEOE  POWER.
YOU  TO SACRIFTHAT.
EBODY CUTS OFF F ATION BECAUSE
TOO MANY PEOPLE BUSINE -I THINK,
, IT'S ACROSS  A
YBODY NO
DIGITABI
PEOPLE DON'TSKT QUTION, AWYER.
HEUL ASKEDSE W THIS.
THIAUSE OFTHE BROTHER.  ON' IOH
LIFETI
DILET M
THE HOOK BUT THERE'S NER MOM
THIS AS